un amigo tommy ha también conocida como
tímpanos tome a o tímpano tome a es un
procedimiento quirúrgico para extraer
líquido del oído medio y restablecer la
misma presión de aire a ambos lados del
tímpano el oído consta de tres partes
principales el oído externo
el oído medio
y el oído interno
el oído externo incluye el pabellón
auricular que recolecta las ondas
sonoras y el canal auditivo que
transporta las ondas sonoras al tímpano
una capa muy delgada de tejido que
separa el oído externo del oído medio
las ondas sonoras hacen que el tímpano
vibre lo que a su vez hace vibrar tres
huesos muy pequeños del oído medio
llamados martillo
young
y estribo
qué pasa en las vibraciones del sonido
hacia el oído interno
el oído interno traduce las vibraciones
en señales eléctricas que son recogidas
por el nervio auditivo enviadas al
cerebro e interpretadas como sonido este
proceso complejo ocurre instantáneamente
y nos permite escuchar los sonidos que
se producen alrededor nuestro
para que el tímpano vibre adecuadamente
la presión del aire en el oído medio
debe estar al mismo nivel de presión que
el aire fuera del oído el aire ingresa
al oído medio a través del tubo de
eustaquio o tubo auditivo cuando usted
bosteza y escucha una pequeña explosión
el tubo de eustaquio ha transportado una
burbuja de aire al oído medio para
igualar la presión una afección alergia
massa o adenoides agrandadas pueden
bloquear el tubo de eustaquio lo que
produce la acumulación de líquido en el
oído medio el líquido evita que el
tímpano vibre adecuadamente bloquea la
transmisión normal del sonido a través
del oído medio y puede causar pérdida
auditiva en algunas instancias el
líquido puede infectarse con bacterias
lo que da como resultado otitis media o
infección del oído
las razones para llevar a cabo una mirin
goto mía son las siguientes drenaje del
líquido atrapado en el oído durante más
de tres meses tratamiento de infecciones
auditivas crónicas que no mejoran con
antibióticos restauración de pérdida
auditiva causada por acumulación de
líquido impedimento de demoras en el
desarrollo del habla en niños debido a
la pérdida auditiva o examen del líquido
del oído medio para detectar bacterias
antes de la cirugía se colocará una vía
intravenosa en la mayoría de los casos
se utiliza anestesia general para que el
paciente duerma durante todo el
procedimiento
el cirujano hará una pequeña incisión en
el tímpano utilizando un bisturí o láser
para drenar el líquido del oído medio en
muchos casos el cirujano colocará un
tubo de ventilación o tubo pp a través
de la incisión este pequeño tubo hará
drenar todo el líquido que se acumule
después de la cirugía y permitirá el
ingreso de aire al oído medio para
ayudar a secarlo si fuera necesario
el cirujano repetir el procedimiento en
el oído opuesto el procedimiento
completo dura entre 30 y 60 minutos la
incisión en el tímpano cicatrizará sola
por lo tanto no se requieren puntos
luego de la cirugía el paciente pasará a
la sala de recuperación para ser
monitoreado los niños pueden volverse
quisquillosos después del procedimiento
se les deberá alentar a comer y beber
todo lo que puedan tolerar si su hijo
siente dolor evite las aspirinas y en su
lugar utilicé acetaminofeno a una dosis
específica para la edad si fuera
necesario aliviar el dolor de otra
manera el médico le puede recomendar
otras opciones el tubo
generalmente se desprende sólo dentro
varios meses